in the famous Disney song Pocahontas
sang colors of the winds and we learned
that everyone can get along despite
their cultural differences while the
intent behind the movie may have been
good it's nowhere near being
historically accurate the true story
it's much darker and for some of you out
there this video might just ruin some of
your childhood memories because today
we're looking at the true story of
Pocahontas the first thing you should
know about Pocahontas is that her birth
name was not Pocahontas Native Americans
have a unique tradition when it comes to
someone's name and identity children are
given a name birth and it often changes
as the person grows up and the family
learns more about the personality at
birth our name was Emma notes and as she
grew older she was developing into a
true beauty so her father gave her the
new name Mitaka which means the flower
between two streams she was a part of
the Powhatan tribe of Eastern Virginia
which had a population of over 25,000
people they were broken into roughly 30
smaller tribes which were governed by
respected village leaders pocum's is his
father whose it's--wow senic or maybe
it's spelled like this he was one head
chief who was above all other tribal
leaders and he was known as honorable
Chief Powhatan about own people had a
tradition where one woman from each
tribe was sent to become one of the
wives of the Chief Powhatan women came
of age 14 years old and they often found
a husband soon after that so it's likely
they would also be around this age when
they were chosen once the young women
gave birth to this baby and Wiens them
she could leave the child to be raised
by the chief and go back to her home
village to get married and start her own
family well it sounds like a frightening
prospect for the modern world this was
considered to be a huge honor only the
most beautiful and intelligent girls
were chosen to have children with the
chief so that they could pass on the
best traits of the tribe together these
children of the chief were given special
training and often grew up to be the
next generation of leaders in the
community there was one wife who had a
special place in the Chiefs heart he
gave her the nickname Pocahontas which
means of a playful one when he was
raising her daughter Hammond who's he
noticed that the girl's personality was
exactly like another he started to call
her Pocahontas as well because they were
so much alike there is no historic
record of what happened to her mother
but most historians believe that she
must have died during childbirth as a
young girl Motoko would run through the
forest and climb trees and do cartwheels
she was always laughing and smiling
ready and willing to play with her
dozens of half-siblings her mother's
name it truly did suit her so at age 14
when she went through her coming-of-age
ceremony she chose to officially change
her name to Pocahontas in the early 1600
crews of British explorers gathered
supplies on their ships and sailed
towards the new world once they arrived
they founded the Jamestown Colony in
1607 one of these explorers was a man
named John Smith who was dubbed the
president of Virginia and Admiral of New
England's he would later publish a book
bragging about his adventures which many
modern-day historians know is just
mostly fiction Smith claims that singing
after he arrived in Virginia he was
captured by a man named open Chanakya
and he was tied up and paraded around
all 30 villagers then he was brought to
chief wahoo Seneca who ordered his
execution
apparently he accepted his fate with
dignity but just as his head was about
to be smashed on a rock a beautiful girl
named Pocahontas comes to his rescue
begging her father for mercy according
to him she said that if he must kill
John Smith then she should die as well
he goes on to talk about then you found
friendship kind of sounds like the
Disney movie rice but most historians
agree that this sounds completely
ridiculous for so many reasons first of
all Pocahontas would only been nine or
ten years old at the time and John Smith
was twenty-seven children were never
allowed to be near anything as brutal as
a trial or an execution the story also
paints the Native Americans as being
savage and willing to kill anyone
without a valid reason the true story is
that in 1608 the Jamestown colonists
were starving because they had run out
of supplies instead of trying to
negotiate a fair trade John Smith
ordered his men to attack the tribal
villages and steal whatever they could
he would also set fires and demanded
that they give in to his demands
however the weakened colonists were no
match for the tribe so many of the wise
men were killed or taken prisoner John
Smith was their leader and he begged the
chief to spare his life Chief Powhatan
chose to howl
mercy on John Smith without Pocahontas
being involved at all later John Smith
would spot the beautiful little girl
playing with her friends when he found
out that Pocahontas was the Chiefs
favorite daughter
he made a mental note of it and I'll bet
away for later
[Music]
when she was 14 or 15 years old
Pocahontas married a young man named
cocoon who was the brother of one of the
village leaders known as Jarvis or she
moved to this new place to be with her
husband and this village was much closer
to Jamestown than where she grew up the
news of this new princess moving into
the tribes village spread so even the
colonists they knew of Pocahontas
arrival John Smith also remembered from
years before that she was the Chiefs
favorite in the summertime that Native
Americans would walk around naked when
it got too hot outside to them there was
nothing sexual or explicit about it they
were all just people trying to keep cool
but to the English settlers in Jamestown
this was shocking and considering that
many of these were men who already saw
the natives as less than human and they
hadn't been with a woman in a very long
time well you can guess what happens
women and children were taken from their
homes and they were violated in power
town culture if a man committed sexual
assault the rapist was immediately
sentenced to death as soon as they see
that someone is a rapist or a murderer
they're gone there's no rehabilitation
they simply will never pass on their DNA
it's just sorted this made the crime
extremely rare in England though men got
away with rape all the time women were
often accused of lying unless there was
a witness which of course they're honest
never was even if the man was caught the
punishments were far from a death
sentence so the power turns they
interpreted this as an act of war and
they were ready to attack Jamestown and
thus began the first Anglo Partin war
meanwhile Pocahontas was now sixteen
years old and heavily pregnant the white
men in Jamestown devised a plan that
they would kidnap her and user as
leverage to stop Chief Powhatan from
completely obliterating the colony
Pocahontas had just given birth to her
first baby she would have been in the
care of the tribal women and away from
her husband cocoon soon after delivering
her child a white man named captain
Samuel Argyll snuck into Pocahontas tent
in the middle of the night and kidnapped
her physically weakened recovering from
giving birth Pocahontas didn't stand a
chance at defending herself in his book
John Smith described the scene of
Pocahontas being carried to the
Englishman's massive ship she had never
seen this technology before so she was
screaming in horror as her abductors
forced her inside there was a jail cell
in the bottom of Captain Argyll's boat
which is where they locked her up in
this version of the story John Smith
blamed everything on the Native
Americans he wrote that the Powerton had
stolen
weapons and supplies from Jamestown and
they were using Pocahontas as leverage
to broker a peace treaty even though he
writes about her distress he never goes
into further detail about what happened
to her according to the Native Americans
oral history Pocahontas is husband Kaku
heard the news that she had been
kidnapped kou-kun gallops towards
Jamestown the next day killing men with
his arrows as he went he made it all the
way to captain Argyll's ship but he was
gunned down before he could save her
John Smith wrote that they kept
Pocahontas while they waited for payment
from Chief Powhatan he says we received
part of the payment and returned a
father this answer that his daughter
should be well used but we could not
believe the rest of our arms we're
either lost or stolen from him and
therefore till he sends them we would
keep his daughter so basically this
guy's justifying kidnapping a teenage
girl and blackmailing her father and
somehow the English thought this was
totally acceptable when they read it in
this book
of course those weapons never came
because there never been stolen in the
first place Pocahontas eventually fell
into a state of depression we know from
the Native American oral history that
she stopped eating because she missed
her family so much the colonists needed
to keep her alive for leverage so her
sister was finally allowed to visit when
the two women were allowed to speak
Pocahontas told her that she was being
raped by the crew of the ship on a
regular basis she begged to come home
but the Englishmen were refusing to let
her leave and as her father promised to
give them weapons and supplies and sign
a peace treaty but of course chief while
Seneca was never going to stop the war
until he got his daughter back
[Music]
rekkles show that the first Anglo part
and war lasted from 1610 to 1614 but the
timeline of events gets a blurry
according to John Smith Pocahontas was
only on the ship for three months but if
you actually think about it logically
she must have been kept prisoner for at
least a year if not longer
some records claims that she was
kidnapped near the beginning of the war
in 1610 while others say that it
happened in 1613 this is also why many
history books are fuzzy about her exact
age and date of birth because there are
so many conflicting stories of exactly
what happens what we do know for certain
is that during her time as a prisoner
Pocahontas became pregnant by one of the
men now that there was a child on the
way the men could no longer hide the
facts that she had been raped in
captivity it would seem then that there
was no hope in negotiating a peace
treaty they needed to come up with a
plan to cover up their crimes this is
where John Rolfe enters the picture he
is credited for being the first man to
bring tobacco farming to the Jamestown
Colony he was able to build a
sustainable business for the colonists
and make a profit by growing tobacco and
shipping it to England since there was
so much land in this new world to back
it became a booming business so if you
don't already hate his guts by the end
of this story you can basically blame
him for bringing bad smoking habits and
lung cancer to the Western world Rolfe
was a widower in his 40s he was friends
with all of those men who would keep him
Pocahontas prisoner and he may have been
one of the rapists as well he offered to
take one for the team
and marry her the only trouble was that
an English person could not marry a
Native American because they were
considered less than human Pocahontas
was forced to go through a Christian
baptism because it was the only way that
they would even consider that she might
have a human soul she was baptized in
the Anglican Church and given a new
English name Rebecca shortly after her
baptism she was forced to marry John
Rolfe now the role from Pocahontas were
marries they sealed the deal the
colonists claimed that the two had
fallen in love once chief while Seneca
saw that his daughter was safe and
apparently happy the peace treaty was
finally negotiated this became known as
the Peace of Pocahontas because from
that day onward the Jamestown colonists
and the power town tribe were finally
able to stop fighting if only for a few
years even though her father had agreed
to the peace treaty in the hopes of
getting her back she was never allowed
to see her family again
[Music]
once she was married to John Rolfe
Pocahontas was forced to begin a new
life in England the Martin people had a
tradition of tattooing their bodies even
the women had face tattoos which had
some people to believe that Pocahontas
may have had them as well but since
women were so covered up in England's
back fairness may have been easy to hide
her ink from the perspective of the
English people this was a wonderful love
story to people from vastly different
cultures were able to fall in love in
the new world where anything can happen
but of course not everyone was drinking
the kool-aid
during an interview someone asked John
Rolfe if he truly loved her normally if
someone asks you to prove your love for
your significant other maybe you'd start
gushing about all of their wonderful
qualities but John Rolfe responded that
if he was actually trying to take
advantage of a teenager he would have
chosen a white girl who was more
pleasing to the eye despite all the
glaringly obvious issues with a 40 year
old marrying a 17 year old this
narrative that Pocahontas was choosing a
white husband and converting to
Christianity was also assigned to white
people that maybe these natives weren't
so savage after all they became so
popular that people wanted to start
making souvenirs of their union
portraits were even painted and sold of
Pocahontas and John Rolfe these happy
stories became so popular in English
culture that their fictional romance was
published in newspapers everywhere and
it even inspired the Disney movie
Pocahontas to genre off claims that the
unborn child was his of course and when
Pocahontas gave birth to a son who they
named Thomas Rolfe
he was also baptized as a Christian
legally speaking John Rolfe was taking
all of their responsibilities as a
father he signed his name on both their
marriage certificate as well as on
Thomas's birth certificate John Rolfe
got to enjoy Pocahontas newfound fame
and popularity as she was invited to the
best parties in the country and she
became a household name portraits were
commissioned of her wearing the
traditional European clothing and she
learned how to speak fluent English
she was foster styler hair and wear
makeup like an English woman and
completely conformed their society
everyone now called her Rebecca Rolfe in
stead of her chosen name despite the
fact that she was a woman who had been
abused and taken from her home
Pocahontas handled her new duty as a
diplomat with grace she was representing
the part on people and everyone called
her the Indian princess
Pocahontas was incredibly polite to all
of these new English
peopleand represented her tribe to the
best of her ability after meeting Queen
Anne and King James view of Native
Americans it completely changed they
could see that these people actually did
have souls and they began to push for a
more peaceful coexistence between the
colonists of the new world and the
natives a few months after arriving in
England John Smith finally stopped by
for a visit
by now PO condors had learned of all the
fictional stories he had written about
having a relationship with her in fact
she had thought John Smith was dead
after he was arrested for what he had
done to their villages she had no idea
that he had used her name to create a
fictional universe where her entire
tribe was full of savages and she was
the one person who had a hope of having
a soul he created a best-selling book
based on these lies that was stained
with the blood of the innocent seething
with rage Pocahontas confronted John
Smith she told him that he was
exploiting her family for the sake of
his own glory she said your countrymen
will lie much
as we mentioned earlier John Rolfe owns
a tobacco farm in Virginia but he lived
in England and managed the incoming
shipment of his product Roth's ships
were going back and forth to Virginia on
a regular basis and Pocahontas begged
him to at a return home on one of them
the better she got at speaking English
the more dangerous it became for the men
who captured her and lied about it as
time went on it became possible that she
would eventually expose the truth
so in 1617 when their son was two years
old he finally agreed to bring them back
to visit her family not long after they
set sail
Pocahontas contracted a mysterious
illness and died while on the boat while
there is no record of what killed her
most assumes that it must have been one
of the many illnesses that the English
had built up an immunity to at the time
no one dead suggests that it might have
been foul play when she dies they turned
the ship around and returned to England
Pocahontas was married and st. George's
Church in Gravesend Rolfe could have
afforded to give his wife the best
funeral money could buy but she was
given a pauper's burial in an unmarked
grave young Thomas was sick with the
same illness that had killed his mother
instead of helping to nurse his son back
to health and help him cope with the
trauma of losing his mother John Rolfe
left him with some random dude called
sir Lewis starkly and sailed back to
Virginia because if we know anything
about modern times it's that leaving
kids to live with strange men on their
own has always worked out perfectly fine
Thomas made a full recovery but it was
clear that John Rolfe no longer wanted
anything to do with him in his mind he
knew that the boy probably wasn't his
biological son anyway and it would seem
as if he felt no fatherly love towards
him at all John's brother Henry Rolfe
finally learns that his nephew was being
watched over by the Stuckey guy and he
quickly jumped in take custody of the
boy Henry was shocked by his brothers
cold-heartedness and willingness to
abandon his own son with a complete
stranger even though John Rolfe was
wealthy from tobacco farming he refused
to give any money to his brother for
child support
Henry Rolfe actually had to sue John in
court demanding that his a nephew be
left with something John Rolfe never had
any other descendants so when he died
Thomas inherited the tobacco farm in
Virginia he was twenty years old this
was the first time the Thomas Rolfe had
sailed back to Virginia from England now
he was a wealthy landowner he had to
learn about the tobacco farming business
he also became left
the Jamestown Colony Thomas grew up
hearing about the stories of his mother
Pocahontas and he knew that his
grandfather half sister and many of his
aunts and uncles would have been
overjoyed to see him by this time there
have been several wars and conflicts
between the Native Americans and the
colonists there were now strict rules
that the colonists should not interact
with Native Americans and vice-versa
Thomas Rolfe tried to petition the
governor of Virginia to let him meet his
family but his request was denied he
lived among the white colonists of
Jamestown if he ever found a way to
speak to his relatives he would have had
to do so in secret and there would never
be a record of it
so yeah this story it's just incredibly
tragic and kind of infuriating and we
wish there was a happy ending
unfortunately though sometimes bad guys
win but if it were not for Pocahontas as
resilience and strength this story could
have been a lot worse she was such a
special person that she was able to
prove to the English that the natives
truly did have souls and it was worthy
that they maintain their culture if
there is any light in this dark story
it's that Pocahontas became a well-loved
icon for hundreds of years for all of
the historic inaccuracies the movie
inspires a love and understanding of
Native American culture instead of
focusing on the darkest parts of her
past the world has chosen to celebrate
her best qualities her friendliness that
kindness and her diplomacy
she chose to embrace the name that she
gave herself the playful one because at
the end of the day it's still who she
truly was so now I'm gonna ask if you
enjoyed that one but please feel free to
vent your frustrations in the comments
below or if you're trying to cheer up
after hearing that story please do give
it a like also do subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you'd like to learn
about more videos from us and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]